what is the secret to be able to have
discipline while practicing slow living
and is there actually a relationship
between the two because usually when we
think of slow living we think of slowing
down and savoring life and then when we
think of discipline we might think go go
go and taking action and it can seem
like the two are Polar Opposites that
can't really mix together but I beg to
differ today I want to share with you
two examples from my personal life where
I can see a night and day difference in
terms of the approach that I had towards
discipline one was what I think is kind
of the traditional way that we tend to
think of discipline where I was focused
on perfectionism I was focused on
results and I was focusing on my goals
and the other is what I think of as slow
living discipline where I'm focusing on
growth I'm focusing on progress and I
think that the distinction lies in that
slow living is really based on intention
and mindfulness but I want to make it
very clear that I'm coming to you as
somebody that has failed miserably in
this department and actually when I was
thinking of making this video I thought
to myself who am I to make a video on
disciplin I'm not like this marathon
runner I'm not some incredibly
disciplined individual and this is
precisely why I want to talk about it
because I failed at it because there was
a time in my life where I was very very
disciplined I was killing it in terms of
discipline but I was unhappy and I was
unfulfilled and the approach that I have
towards discipline now is something that
leaves me with progress but at the same
time acceptance of myself and of my
flaws and today I want to share with you
how having intention and having
mindfulness was really what allowed me
to be able to switch the approach that I
had towards discipline and how I'm so
much better because of it but this is
coming from somebody that was eating M
up on candies 10 minutes before bed last
night but who at the same time was not
beating herself up for it and is up at
4:30 a.m. filming this video today so to
me my Approach for discipline is not
that of perfection and I once had such
an approach if I made a mistake I beat
myself up for it and I wasn't living in
the present so slow living is being
present being mindful but when we're so
focused on Perfection on results we tend
to think in the future the results that
I'm going to have the goals that I have
the way that I want my life to be and
then when we mess up and we make a
mistake we live in the past and we're
thinking I shouldn't have done that I
shouldn't have said that I should have
done this and we're not ever now here
and for me slow living is definitely
what made the biggest difference in
terms of my discipline and just
improving my results in different areas
of my life before I continue with the
video hey I'm yesie and I do want to
apologize for my raspy voice I have a
bit of a cold and if this video is a bit
choppy it's likely because I needed to
cough or because I needed to drink some
tea but thank you for putting up with
that I can think of no two better
examples of how my Approach discipline
changed the course of my life and for me
these were pregnancy and postpartum
periods so the first pregnancy and
postpartum that I had I was super
disciplined this was at a time in my
life where I had just come across Dave
Ramsey and the fire movement and let me
tell you I was on fire we wanted to get
out of debt at that point in time my
husband and I rented a three bed two
bath home and I had stuff in every
single one of those rooms I am ashamed
to admit it I definitely had a lot of
stuff but I was selling things left and
right and I was working overtime almost
every single week I was pregnant okay I
was working overtime all the time and I
was working as a nurse working 12-hour
shifts during that time Not only was I
trying to get out of debt and working
hard working overtime almost every
single week I was also introduced to the
vegan diet and so I was eating these
wonderful plant-based meals and meal
prepping these beautifully uh made
dishes and my snacks at lunch while I
was pregnant people would laugh at me
because I would take carrots uh
cucumbers celery sticks and peanut
butter I would take this like big jug
with me to work because I wanted to make
sure that I got enough water I would
wake up at 5:00 a.m. to be able to
exercise before I went to work and I was
exercising about 3 to 5 days a week um
running a few miles a week as well I was
just super disciplined I didn't need any
junk food didn't need any candies I was
just focused on making sure to be as
healthy as possible and reading books
and doing a lot of things because I just
wanted to completely change me and
change who I was I wanted to be better
but see the thing is those things were
great and I was killing it in terms of
discipline but I wasn't happy because no
matter what I did I wasn't good enough
for myself and especially once I the 6
weeks period pass and I was then able to
exercise after I had my baby I was doing
too much too fast and because I was
approaching it from this very
perfectionist mindset from really
results oriented I did way too much too
fast and I ended up hurting myself I
ended up getting sick I had to go to the
hospital I had diastasis recti and then
because I had diastasis recti I ended up
backtracking because then I had to treat
that before I could actually treat the
belly pooch and all that so really I
ultimately hurt myself because my
expectations were that of results I
wasn't focusing on compassion this to me
is that clear distinction this made that
night and day difference
self-compassion and when I mentioned
that when we think of slow living and
being able to be mindful and being able
to be intentional to me the compassion
that we have towards oursel is what
makes that difference because it is what
can allow me to accept my flaws accept
my phase of life so I worked in hospice
and working in hospice I was basically
working with people that are at stages
end stages of Life uh basically
everybody is dying and having had such
an experience to me I can now appreciate
the fact that life has phases and I find
that so many times in my life I was
trying to rush past certain phases
rather than being able to accept what I
couldn't change but focusing on growth
focusing on progress focusing on doing
the little things that I could do to be
better at that stage of my life yeah I
was super disciplined but I was never
good enough I looked at myself in the
mirror and I thought I was disgusting I
was saying horrible things to myself and
my results were never going to be good
enough because I was approaching it from
perfectionism and I really want to take
a moment here to talk about
perfectionism because I feel like our
society makes perfectionism seem like
this Grand thing like if you say you're
a perfectionist at a job interview
you're just automatically going to be
hired because it makes you better
somehow I beg to differ and I think that
as somebody that has struggled with
perfectionism and people pleasing it is
detrimental Al behavior and it can
absolutely not only ruin your life but
the people around you because they can
never make you happy because you can
never be happy with yourself so yeah
that's just my little tidbit on
perfectionism it's it's horrible
horrible horrible but that was me that
was me back in the day and I can see a
difference where this time around my
second pregnancy I had become aware of
slow living and I was by that time in my
life I knew that I had made that mistake
the first time and I didn't want to make
that mistake again so I did a few things
very very differently when I approached
discipline so yesie number one was super
hardworking and super diligent and was
never eating the junk food and I would
always work out and never miss a workout
the yessie number two was a lot more
kind to herself and this yessie it what
she wanted still try to eat healthy but
if I was tired and I slept instead of
exercising I didn't beat myself up for
it I was kind to myself I listened to my
body and I listened to you know what I
don't need an exercise right now I need
a nap and I was much more at peace with
being able to listen to my body and the
way in which I spoke to myself
completely changed that is what I think
made the biggest difference so I
mentioned compassion I think that when
you have discipline from an aspect of
compassion your results are going to be
so much better in the long run because
you're not being Your Own Worst Enemy I
was definitely My Own Worst Enemy when I
was at my most disciplined self so that
yesie was achieving results but it was
from an aspect of beating myself down so
if I ever messed up I was beating myself
up thinking I shouldn't have done that
and I was just constantly ruminating on
the past and constantly focusing on what
I wanted to achieve in the future now
this time around this last pregnancy it
was completely different and there are
some things that I did that really
really really helped me so first thing
is small winds or tiny winds every night
before I went to bed I would write down
three to five things that went right
three to five things that I was proud of
myself for or that I did well and it
could even be as Tiny as I took a shower
and really actually I want to stop
myself because I think that if you're
going through some sort of a mental
health issue or depression or postpartum
because the hormone fluctuations taking
a shower like that's a huge win because
it's self-care that's a way in which you
tell yourself I love you here in the
last month I went to a couple of
weddings and when I go to weddings love
is at the Forefront of my mind and I am
somebody that is a very firm believer
that love isn't just a feeling it's an
action so when I wake up in the middle
of the night to take care of my sick
kids that shows that I love them but
sometimes I wonder to myself why is it
that it's so much easier sometimes to do
things for other people and to love
other people than it is to do that for
ourselves to me that time in my life
when I was postpartum and I was pregnant
clearly shows me the ways in which I was
really causing my own detriment because
of my mindset because of the things that
were going on in my mind and when I
started writing things down at night
that went right that I did well even as
Tiny as they might seem what I was doing
was priming my brain for positivity
being my own cheerleader and not
focusing on all the hor things that went
wrong you can often have days where you
feel like this went wrong and I didn't
do this and I should have exercised and
I should have done that but if we're
thinking about all those things before
we go to bed we're really only beating
ourselves up and what I was doing by
writing those small wins at night was
focusing on okay I didn't do the things
that I wanted to do I didn't make as
much progress as I wanted to but I did
this and I did this and I did this and
it might be super tiny but at least I
made progress and what it did without
knowing it was it started making my
brain start to focus on progress rather
than perfectionism so that previous yesi
was all perfectionism and she was never
happy this yesie was focusing on I am
improving I did one little thing I did
this little thing and the other thing
that I did was when I looked at my
myself in the mirror this time I just
showered myself with lots of positive
affirmations and I remember at the time
when I was thinking about positive
affirmations I would just kind of scoff
at the idea and think well I don't
really believe that but this time I
really really really wanted to make a
change I wanted to believe it so what I
would do is I would look at myself in
the mirror and I would tell myself I am
beautiful I am worthy I am loved I am
valuable and what that did was it kind
of started the habit of being kind to
myself and anytime that I would start to
say negative things to myself like G I'm
disgusting our bodies are just not the
same when we've had a baby and and my
hormone fluctuations were not the same
either but I was being was so mean to
myself the first time around I was cruel
cruel to myself and this time around I
wanted to be very aware so this is where
slow living helped me I was aware of my
thoughts but I didn't fall prey to them
anymore I was aware that I was saying
things that weren't nice to myself but I
was also then able to take a step back
and say oh every time I would think of
something negative I would immediately
think of something positive to tell
myself so if I told myself I'm so dumb I
haven't learned this then immediately my
next thought that I would think to
myself is I'm making progress I'm
learning I'm trying so anytime I would
think anything negative throughout the
entire day I would immediately try to
follow up with something positive and
what that was doing was almost like
giving myself a slap in the hand anytime
I would do something negative with
replacing it with a positive habit I was
changing ing my thinking habits this is
where I think I made so much more
progress I actually was so much more
lenient on myself and I like I said I
took naps I kind of ate what I wanted
and I did have some junk food while I
was pregnant and postpartum and this
time around but I healed so much faster
I bounced back so much faster and I
hands down think it was because of my
mindset because my Approach was coming
from compassion and awareness I was
aware of the downfalls that I have I was
aware of the negative thinking patterns
that I have they're habits but I was
also able to accept myself flaws and all
this doesn't mean that I just
automatically say well I hurt this
person's feelings and I'm fine with that
actually as somebody like I said who's
struggled with people placing those
sorts of things are very tough for me I
hate when somebody is disappointed in me
when I've hurt somebody when I've said
something I shouldn't have said I
contend to beat myself up for it so the
awareness is key here because I know
myself myself enough to know that about
myself now but I'm also accepting of
myself now realizing that I can't change
the past it already did happen I'm not
going to ruminate and live on the past
but I am going to focus on what I can do
now what maybe I can say or try to do to
be able to change the situation in the
future I can focus on improving now and
my mindset changed to that of
improvement rather than trying to
achieve a certain result and trying to
force the results to happen and I think
I was wasn't all too happy during that
stage of my life because I was trying to
force things to be a certain way but
with slow living we realize that we
can't always have things the way that we
want them and as I said having worked in
hospice I realize life has phases and
there's different aspects of our life
that are going to change throughout our
phases and we can't always have the same
approach to discipline throughout those
stages of life so for me coming at it
from an aspect of compassion and being
kind to to myself throughout it being my
own cheerleader was what made a huge
difference towards my progress around
this time of year a lot of us think of
new ways in which we can improve our
lives and set resolutions especially New
Year's resolutions for me usually my my
biggest New Year's is Easter time lent
season I I think of a lot of things that
I kind of fast from and and Chang in my
life to me that's like my reset and I
love a good reset I think we all kind of
intrinsically want a reset a start over
a refreshing and I think it's awesome
it's amazing but you have to realize
that there is going to be people in your
life that are going to tear you down and
often times friends and family are the
ones that are the biggest culprits to me
at least friends and family are the ones
that have the biggest ability to be able
to hurt me because they know me the best
and they know how to push my buttons
versus other random strangers that might
say something and it doesn't really
bother me because I don't even know them
and I might not ever see them again like
the time I once got punched in the back
by a random stranger it's probably
drugged but I didn't really care I just
kind of turned around I'm like what's up
with you
why okay it wasn't worth my time but
with family like if family randomly just
punched me in the back and be like hey
that that hurt like I would probably
have a bigger issue with somebody that I
love somebody that I know versus a
complete random stranger so already
knowing that people are going to tear
you down why would you be Your Own Worst
Enemy and I say that not in a judgmental
way but because I was that person I was
that person that would say these
horrible things to myself in the mirror
and and I would beat myself up for the
mistakes that I made versus now where I
can still fall prey to those things
every now and then but at the same time
recognize that well I have these flaws
and I'm trying to work on them but
progress is better than nothing and at
least I'm trying so I'm congratulating
myself for the fact that I'm trying so
this video if you can take anything away
from it I'd like to leave you with some
homework actually and if you want to
accept that homework and accept this
challenge give me a high five in the
comments below and let me know you're
going to take on this challenge so the
first thing is every single night before
you go to bed have a piece of paper have
a little notebook put it right beside
your bed or actually even on your bed on
your pillow so that every night before
you go to bed you see this and you have
to move it physically to be able to get
in the bed and at night think of three
to five positive things that happened
that day three to five things that you
did right maybe you drank a glass of
water when you got up maybe it's
something tiny those things will slowly
start to change your mindset and you
will slowly become your own cheerleader
I assure you that if you start to think
of yourself in a more positive way if
you start to be kinder to yourself the
whole discipline aspect it doesn't
really become as big of an issue at that
time in my life where I was I thought at
my most disciplined self it is a
completely different change from now
where I'm still taking cold showers I
still exercise but not as often as I did
back then and if I miss one I'm not I'm
not beating myself up anymore like I
said I ate some candy and it's fine but
at the same time I'm still doing a lot
more things that I never thought I would
be able to do like I've had a 4 and 1/2
day fast that in the past I never would
have thought that I could actually
complete a 4 and a half day fast not
saying that you need to do that but I'm
saying that you can achieve levels of
discipline that you might never have
imagined if you come at it from the
right mindset the positive mindset
compassionate mindset and present
actually being present when I take a
cold shower in the morning I'm I'm
definitely present I'm oo I feeling all
the cold water and whenever we approach
discipline with mindfulness I just feel
like the results are going to be so much
better and I'm just so excited for what
is to come for you if you do take on
this challenge of thinking of your
positive wins writing them down and if
you want some extra credit let me tell
you there's not going to be any better
thing that you can do than looking at
yourself in the mirror the next day when
you wake up and saying positive
affirmations so for me the one thing
that I really needed to tell myself my
pregnancy the second time around was I'm
beautiful I'm beautiful I'm beautiful I
it was really hard to accept that my
body was just not the same anymore uh
that my hair had fallen out that things
were not in the same positions as they
were before and I really needed to tell
myself that not hear from my husband not
hear from my family but me to believe it
within myself and saying positive
affirmations were really what kind of
let me to start throughout the day
saying positive things to myself being
kinder to myself being gentler to myself
being encouragement kind of like my own
coach kind of like a friend encourages
somebody else when they've Fallen when
they've made a mistake I mean if your
friend fell if your friend did something
that they shouldn't have done would you
tear them down would you yell at them
and nag at them or would you encourage
them and and say you get up try again do
it again be that same friend for you
every single morning look at yourself in
the apples actually
look at your reflection of your eyes in
the mirror and say I love you I love you
I love you I love you and it might sound
so silly and it might be awkward at
first but the more you actually start to
do those things to drink your water in
the morning to do whatever those little
tiny winds are for you because you know
best what your Achilles heels are I know
mine I have lots of flaws and lots of
weaknesses and things that I need to
improve on but as you start to slowly do
those things and at night you're
focusing on oh I did that I did that
you're basically telling yourself hey
this is what I did to show you that I
love you so just in the same example
that I told you of how I show my kids
that I love them when I get up through
the night to take care of them when
they're sick even though I'm sick
myself you're basically doing the same
thing you're showing yourself you're
proving to yourself I love you and soon
there will come that moment when you
look at yourself in the mirror and you
say I love you and you smile because you
realize you know you've had your back
enough times to know that you're going
to be yourself that you're going to be
there for yourself because you've shown
up in the past I am super excited for
the changes that can be to come in your
life if you do this because these two
changes this this priming of my brain
for positivity for being present for
accepting what is but still trying to be
better and trying to improve is really
it completely changed me in in a
positive way when I was at my best
discipline wise I was at my worst and I
was crying all the time almost every
single day and I I struggled to ask for
help because I didn't want to show
people that I was
incompetent and now I'm happy to admit
I'm very incompetent in a lot of things
and it don't it doesn't make me feel any
weaker actually it kind of empowers me
to then be able to be vulnerable and
realize that I'm not alone
and it can be more encouraging and more
strengthening in an odd way to be
vulnerable so I'm just super excited for
the possibilities in your life because
first of all you clicked on a video on
discipline so it shows that you want to
improve in this area so be proud of
yourself for the fact that you want to
improve that you want to make your life
better to improve your life maybe
improve lives of others but to be able
to improve lives of others you have to
improve yourself you have to love
yourself you have to be compassionate
towards yourself you can't give from an
empty cup and this was a very very tough
lesson for me to learn and it took me
quite some time and I'm still working on
this but doing these things greatly
improved my life so I I hope that you do
them I hope that you do your homework if
you're going to do your homework let me
know give give me that half five down in
the comments below I sincerely hope that
this video has helped you if so please
give it a thumbs up because it really
helps support my channel and if you'd
like to see more videos like this be
sure to subscribe so you won't miss when
I post a new video I thank you so much
for watching and I'll see you in the
next one bye for now